[Music]
[Music]
well in case anyone here doesn't happen
to know cliff schola's 1994 laureate in
physics
[Applause]
but cliff is is sharing the honor with
the brick rock house for McMaster and
the Nobel citation in fact quoted cliff
as being the one who told us where the
atoms are and Bracco's telling us what
they do
cliff was born in Pittsburgh in 1915
there is a you know perhaps apocryphal
story that his great skill intuition in
the laboratory came from his family
hardware and home repair business in
which he was quite active I understand
as a youth kind of degree at the
Carnegie Tech 1937 and went off to NYU
for his graduate studies there he got
into the beginnings of what you might
call nuclear technology with an MIT
connection as during his thesis time he
built a Van de Graaff generator and of
course Van de Graaff was that was a
professor here at that at that time he
did not however work with neutrons at
that time and in fact during the war as
well did not get to work with with the
developing neutrons technology as he was
too valuable in his work with with
Texaco or what is now Texaco working on
high-octane aviation fuel during the war
this time was productive however in of
course in a different way in 1941 he
married Martha with a very important
partnership 50-plus years and and and
going on he did he did get to work with
x-ray diffraction diffraction techniques
which presumably played a major part in
seeding his subsequent activities with
neutrons after the war Clift went to Oak
Ridge and using the large graphite
reactor which was which was developed
there began his study of Neutron
techniques working on that for many many
many decades and of course resulting in
the prize which he said which he
deserves
today I will not get into the work of
with neutrons you'll hear that from
Cliff you'll hear some further remarks
from from other people
in fact I'll just end with some sort of
departmental personal remarks first of
all I think that cliffs colleagues have
a deep appreciation
for as many contributions to the
department his his Pleasant aspect his
dedication to high standards and to to
redoing what he doing experiments and
everyone is extremely delighted with
with this recognition indeed cliff won
the Buckley Prize a very prestigious
prize in condensed matter physics in the
mid-50s and this is really sort of a 40
year overdue recognition by the Nobel
Committee cliff with his characteristic
modesty I think is was genuinely
surprised by the news he received a few
days ago and I would just say that many
of us were far less surprised than he
was since we all feel very very strongly
this was a very timely and a very very
well-deserved prize so we're going to
have a few remarks now before cliff gets
his chance to tell you about about
neutrons and how he helped develop this
important field Chuck vests the
president will say a few a few things
the Dean Bob Birgeneau who is one of our
most active certainly neutron scattering
today will add something and it finally
one of cliffs students state moncton who
was flown in from from argon will give a
brief perspective from from the students
view the Chuck thank you very much I
think that moments like this are
extremely important in the life of a
great institution like MIT and certainly
are extremely important in the life of
science period it's a great honor to be
associated with people who stand for
such excellence in their scientific work
and in their being as humans there are
two things that particularly struck me
as I listened and talked to people I
must admit from the distance because
they've been out of town the last two
days and had to sense all this through
the newspapers and the television and
running into a couple of people
including a former physics student here
from the department in the Washington
area the two things that struck me the
most were first
every single person I have talked to
about this award within the first one or
two sentences has used the word nice
professor Scholl is known as a nice
person which is another way of saying a
warm human being and somebody who is
viewed as being very supportive of his
students and his colleagues of the
institute community the second thing
that really struck me was a quote in the
newspaper it may have been from Bob Byrd
you know I'm sorry if I'm attributing it
to the wrong person that said that they
had worried that the revolution that
Professor Scholl and his colleagues
brought about in the use of neutron
scattering to major properties and
materials and so forth had become so
standard so well-known so much the stuff
of textbooks that they were afraid that
the person who originated it might be
forgotten that is a very strong and very
important statement and I think that one
of the terrific benefits of the Nobel
Prize recognition is that it reminds
people and particularly young people
that there are people behind science and
it is their passion their enthusiasm
their commitment to excellence and
belief and the importance of science
that really drives it forward so we
thank you very much to use a rather
hackneyed phrase I suppose for being
such a fantastic role model for those
who follow behind you professor Scholl
and it's just a very very great honor to
be a member of this MIT community and to
share this moment with you thank you
very much
as many of my friends out there know
this price it's a really extraordinary
pleasure for me because actually I began
my research career as a summer student
in Beart rock houses root chakra and it
was because of Burt Rock House who also
is a nice wonderful person so this is
extraordinary that we had to such a
human being recognized with one prize
and in fact my first publication was
with Rock Hudson's root and
embarrassingly it's still my most
reference publication after having got
launched by Brockhouse I then he and
heard around the world actually and then
finally ended up here at MIT and while I
was learning about this field from rock
lobster and Broncos former cohorts they
had told me how there was this genius
who had created the field in the first
place by name of cliff Shaw who was then
at MIT so it was one of my goals to come
down my team to meet the great person
himself and I remember first walking
down the hallway first time I saw a
cliff and cliff was so nice and so
self-effacing I couldn't believe
especially in the MIT environment that
this modest person was this great hero
that I'd heard about but but indeed it
was and and actually we had many years
together we served in a number of
Academy committees together flying back
and forth to Washington and we shared
one extreme vice which is both cliff and
I like to smoke cigars and cliff had the
wisdom to retire before it was banned
but I presume actually they're still a
residue in his office if you go into his
office name which is now occupied by my
and mark castner's postdocs who are
hoping that some of this greatness rubs
off on besides being a wonderful
colleague and an outstanding scientist
cliff also was a excellent as a
undergraduate and graduate student
teacher and as a graduate mentor and he
educated many of the leaders in the
field one of the premier of those is
Dave London who's associate director at
Argonne National Laboratory and who's
head of the Advanced Photon Source which
is this wonderful new source which we
and many others hope are going to
advance this kind of science that cliff
has done albian using photons instead of
neutrons in that case a level further so
maybe Dave can make a few comments from
the perspective of someone used to sit
here as a graduate student
I'm really overwhelmed by the privilege
of being able to stand up here have the
opportunity to thank cliff personally in
front of this particular audience for
all that he gave to me as a student I'd
like to speak mostly to the students in
the audience I guess the faculty members
can listen in if they'd like the first
the contact that I had with cliff was
when I was still a senior at Cornell I
had applied to only one school as an
undergraduate and realized that that
might be risky as a graduate student so
I had applied to a number of places and
I was fortunate to have gotten accepted
at all of them and I was fortunate also
to have gotten the scholarships of all
of them so I was having a hard time
making up my mind until a letter arrived
in the mail and it was a personal letter
from cliff who had been busy in the
Graduate School office looking over the
applications of graduate students and
personally writing to those people he
thought would fit into his laboratory
and there was no question in my mind
when I read that letter that this was
where I wanted to work I don't think I
took my cap and gown off before I got in
the car and drove from Cornell to
Cambridge and began working in the
summer of 1970 I think the first of July
essentially I was so excited about a
real laboratory and real experiments
that I couldn't think of anything better
to do that summer that's an example of
of cliffs fastidiousness I suppose that
has become legendary and all of his
students will will tell you about that
and it's a gift that I think he's given
all of his students the other night my
wife and I were arguing why it was that
when I go to sleep at night I like to
have all the 3-way switches in my house
all in a down position you don't need to
have them all in the down position some
can be as long as they're up in pairs
then the lights will all still be off
but it seemed to me
but that was not fastidious enough I
mean after all if someone came in in the
middle of night turned on a light and
turned it off I mean you'd know if you
remembered where he left them so
throughout my career as an
experimentalist I always I always tried
to emulate I had never successfully
emulated that level of fastidiousness
that Cliff had brought to bear on
experimental science but I never regret
at any time I did something I lined it
goniometer up to be a zero of angle when
it was perfectly vertical or perfectly
horizontal it didn't have to be defined
as zero there but that just gave you
some clue as to whether it had been
moved inadvertently or the motors had
slipped or what have you because you
could line it up with various other
vertical clues and the horizon and those
are the kinds of things that cliff just
did routinely
when during my I think early in my
second year cliff thought it would be a
good exercise for a student to write a
nobel-prize recommendation so he's told
me that he would like to see Bryan
joseph´s and get the Nobel Prize and
would I go out to the library and take a
crack at writing the case for Bryan
Josephson which I was very enthusiastic
about and i and i did that and i gave it
to clifton and he puckered his lips as
he usually did and held his pipe out and
said thank you
of course that was the last day i saw of
it until Bryan joseph´s and a few months
later got the Nobel Prize
and I thought that was easy little did I
know what work goes on in getting Nobel
Prizes on either side of the equation
the one other gift and the most
important gift that I think cliff gave
me as a teacher was I guess what I call
the gift of self-confidence as an
experimental physicist it's very
important there are lots of bleak
moments there long periods between good
results and and even longer periods
between excellent results and longer
between publishable results and longer
even between results that people want to
read about when you publish them and in
that in those long waits you have to be
confident that you have something to
bring to bear on the field something to
offer and you need to have a lot of
confidence in yourself and what cliff
did was he to a large extent he left me
alone because he had what I believe he
can correct me when when he gets his
chance what I believe is a lot of
confidence in me I didn't work on a
problem that cliff gave me as a thesis
advisor and that was very unusual and I
didn't even work in his own lab finally
on my own thesis I went to Brookhaven
and I worked at their reactor and
throughout the entire period of my
graduate school he was especially in the
later years almost a secondary figure in
my day-to-day life but this tremendous
confidence that he had in me translated
some magical fashion into my own
self-confidence as an experimentalist so
it's not the the you know the book
learning in a sense that that I took
away from my graduate education with
cliff I took it away from MIT because
goodness knows we had many many courses
but what cliff gave me and I think all
of his students was that the
self-confidence
- he himself and you probably won't get
him to admit it but he has it in the in
great quantities that quantity is enough
that he is able to share it with so many
of us so thank you cliff
okay without further delay cliff will
tell us about the development of neutron
scattering
as Ernie has mentioned in Bob the field
of research that I want to mention this
afternoon goes back a long ways back to
the immediate years following World War
two back in the late 1940s and this be
the research deals with the development
of techniques that can utilize slow
neutron radiation
now back at neutrons were first
discovered in 1932 by Chadwick in
England and Chadwick found that if you
take a an alpha particle source and
essentially the only alpha particle
sources known at that time were from
naturally naturally occurring radium
sources if you surround radium sample
with brew some material most usually
beryllium you find that emanating from
the beryllium is in an intense radiation
alpha and that was only later
investigated by Rutherford and other
people
classic people and labeled alpha
particles now it was also found shortly
after Chadwick Chadwick discovered after
when Chadwick it was arranging such
configurations alpha particle sources
and he found that if you further
surrounded that source with other media
that there seemed to be some something
coming away from the other media what
which wasn't there which what was
certainly different than the alpha
particles that were
released from the in her piece of radio
and in on investigating this he found
that it was a very penetrating radiation
and that was the surprising thing to him
it's radiation that could pass through
copious quantities thicknesses of
material and there was no known
radiation at the time that would do that
so with further studies of the
production of this anomalous radiation
with different materials surrounding the
alpha particle source it was a key came
to think of this as being some neutral
particle type of radiation the reason
being that a neutral particle would have
would be expected to have much greater
penetration through media than any sort
of charged particle radiation it was
ruled out that it was an electromagnetic
type of radiation from certain
observations so if it had no charge if
it were radiation without charge it you
could think of it as being somehow
neutral in an electrical charge and he
gave it the name neutron the neutron
radiation well it was this was very
exciting to nuclear physics what what
there was of nuclear physics at the time
nuclear physics was very rudimentary
then and further studies mostly by Fermi
in Italy showed that this radiation
could be effectively thermalized by
again passing it through and letting it
bounce around and some other media
medium and if you observe what comes out
of this this third piece of medium
medium a obtained what he thought what
he classified as thermal neutron
radiation
how could he determine that that it had
this case sort of characteristic by
being thermalized it implied that the
energy was down to thermal energy levels
thermal energy levels that characterize
atom emission of radiation thermal
energy radiation well one thing it was
known that capture cross-sections
absorption cross-sections of materials
would be expected to follow a certain
energy dependence the lower the energy
the greater the absorption and that
indeed was what he found that if he put
more and more media there didn't more
and more acting upon the new this
neutron radiation it lowered the energy
of the radiation so that you could
observe a larger absorption
cross-section in something else
so this process could be could continue
until what he obtained what he thought
was real thermal energy neutron
radiation where the neutrons had been
degraded in kinetic energy down to a
thermal energy level of some fraction of
one electron volt some fraction of one
electron volt so this thermalization
concept was a very important one it was
shortly recognized that if you had
radiation of such a low energy that it
would this radiation would also exhibit
a very anomalous wave character and
that's this goes back to the heart of
quantum mechanics a particle moving
along is to be considered also as a
moving wave and there's a periodicity
associated
wave this was first was suggested in
earlier years most notably by debroglie
debroglie who suggested that there was a
wavelength associated with moving
electron radiation moving electrons
should also exhibit a wave character and
it wasn't long before people did
experiments that demonstrated sure
indeed a moving electron does exhibit a
periodicity and a wavelength and that
was demonstrated by diffracting
low-energy electron beams but from
crystals just as people with x-rays had
demonstrated many years earlier so there
was this periodicity associated with
moving electron radio moving electron
particles now we have neutron particles
that are moving slowly and they should
have a characteristic periodicity also
the question comes do these neutrons
also show diffractive effects the same
as had been observed with electrons some
years earlier so there were two
experiments two experimental groups that
set out to establish to look for this
periodicity this de Broglie wave
character for this neutron radiation von
Halman von Halman and price work in
France and Mitchell and powers at
Columbia University in in the United
States both pursuing experimentation in
1936 and they both found indeed that
this periodicity was there that there
were diffractive effects excuse me
from crystal and material-witness
neutron radiation thermal neutron
radiation was applied to these
diffracting objects so now we have a
wavelength we have a kinetic energy we
have an energy a kinetic energy to be
associated with these particles well
the experiments of demonstrating this
diffractive effect were so accomplished
so complicated than the intensities that
were involved were so small that one we
could hardly think of exploiting it as a
diffractive tool x-ray diffraction was
in a well defined well developed state
by that time and many people were
diffracting x-rays and learning lots of
things about crystals and materials in
general one could think that maybe
neutrons could be also it could also
serve that purpose but the intensities
were frighteningly low and you it was
nobody worried about doing anything
serious seriously in that direction that
all changed a couple years later in 1939
when nuclear fission was uncovered by
Hahn and Meitner in Germany 1939 now the
exciting thing about nuclear fission is
this you bring neutrons on those certain
fissile nuclei most notably uranium
normal uranium and you find that the
neutron absorbs the neutron and breaks
up into fragments and more than two
neutrons come off from that one Neutron
in more than two come
now that these this conclusion didn't
come automatically it came over with a
series of different types of experiments
but that was very very interesting I put
in something and I get over twice that
same thing out that immediately suggests
that that this process could be used in
a cascade manner to produce more than
you feed him and the process could
skyrocket cascade and become cataclysmic
with more coming out than you're putting
in well it wasn't long after that that
we got into the war of war he came and
engaged in war years and it was proposed
thought very seriously by people that
maybe this could be developed into some
sort of weapon weapon an atomic weapon
maybe you could arrange it have a
configuration of system configurational
system that would could be triggered
somehow or other and it would diverge so
many people became involved in that
confirming himself and many of his
colleagues and very well-known people
became involved in that through the what
was called a Manhattan Project set up in
in the early war years it was finally
demonstrated that in experiments at the
University of Chicago at the staggered
athletic field that indeed you could
have a cascading system a reproducing
system of that you think can think of
the idea was to collect enough uranium
and enough graphite together
the graphite was to serve as a
moderating medium for the neutrons the
extra neutrons that came from the
uranium fissioning and the graphite
would cascade the energy down until
those neutrons would then cause further
fission events in other uranium giving
again two for every one or more than two
for everyone and that process would
continue and build up well the chance of
success of obtaining such a
configuration we recognize would go
would increase as the size of this can
as the physical size in this
configuration would get larger because
volume effects go up as the cube of the
size whereas surface area which depth
which determined leakage from the system
go up only as the square root of the
area so the size there's an advantage in
increased size so that test was going to
come when one could get a large enough
configuration of uranium and graphite
collected together into a system this
was obtained and it was detected it was
marked very carefully monitored
monitored by with equipment sensitive
equipment in these in this first
experiment at Stagg field in at the
University of Chicago that occurred in
December 1942 December 1942 once it had
been demonstrated once Fermi had
dispensed rated that indeed you could
have a self reacting system this way
they could the experiment was shut down
they didn't wanted to get out of control
shut down and people immediately started
to design facilities for
making use for for using that a reactor
it was the fifth consider thinking at
that time was to convict to construct a
reacting system off somewhere else
that would produce I said some isotopes
which were badly needed during the
wartime years most notably put isotopes
of plutonium which were to be you which
was considered to be useful in atomic
weapons production so this we had what
they wanted to build this test reactor
this which would operate at a
considerable power level now as a test
production test facility for even larger
facilities which were to be built
elsewhere it was decided to place
position this test reactor at Oak Ridge
Tennessee when the Army had absorbed a
large area there for use of industrial
use and that this reactor was put on
paper construction was carried through
and was completed within a parish in an
amazing period of eleven months December
1942 until the first use of the reactor
in November 1943 eleven months in total
and this was all a thousand five hundred
miles away from Chicago where the first
experiments were carried out so a whole
flock of physicists were conveyed to
sent from from Chicago down to the Oak
Ridge area and engineers galore and
construction people and this amazing
development was pushed through so this
reactor started to operate at Oak Ridge
in in November 1943 and I have a I'll
show shortly a photograph of that but
let me
first projects this they said this is a
chronological listing of the starting of
periods of the very early piles they
were called piles back men reactors
reactor is a term that came in both came
into boldly later on piles the openness
Oakridge graphite power which I was just
describing was it start-up date was in
1943 a year at the same time as the
construction of this reactor was going
on in decent design and construction
another one was under construction back
in Chicago in what was then called the
Argonne laboratory and it differed from
the Oakridge graphite power or is that
this should have actually been written
Clinton graphite Paul Clinton is a town
in Tennessee which is the nearest town
to the Oakridge mokra chat facility so
at that time this was all Clinton and
Oakridge did not which came in later the
Argonne reactor was to differ from the
graphite pal at Geppetto
in the Oakridge area by having a heavy
water instead of graphite as a moderator
medium this the heavy water was to slow
down the neutrons and cause again
fissioning in uranium the same as it is
in this first pal
but with which had graphite as
moderating me at later times in 47 the
chalk river reactor came came into
operation and this is the one where dr.
Brock house did all of his
work up at this Canadian government
facility and then later ones in in
England this is of England and another
one at Oak Ridge and at Brookhaven on
Long Island
in this country my next projection shows
a photograph of this graphite reactor at
Oak Ridge
the reactor is a very large assembly
roughly 20 feet a cubic assembly roughly
20 feet on an edge of stacked graphite
pure graphite components whatever called
graphite stringers so if you these
graphite Springer's were square
configurational chunks of pure graphite
and that was a problem to prepare a
graph graphite of sufficient purity
about 4 or 5 inches on a side and three
or four feet in length rectangular
assembly just back together on the
corners of these graphite sections
graphite pieces there was a diagonal cut
and so when these elements became
stacked together there would be channels
running down along the length in these
channels one was one was to place the
uranium fissioning fuel the uranium was
pure metal uranium many problems
associated with preparing the pure
uranium and that these the uranium had
to be encased because uranium will
oxidize and if it gets hot which it
would in this operation and it would
oxidize very rapidly and become the
uranium oxide and become a powder and
essentially collapse so it had to be
each of the this raid these uranium
pieces which were roughly an inch in
diameter and five inches long an inch in
diameter five inches long had to be in
close encased in an aluminum shielding
can and sealed up to prevent air from
getting to the uranium and oxidizing the
uranium so we think of this
configuration of all this graph
tons of it stacked up not bolted
together or not clamped together because
it would be graphite would become hot
and expand and any banding or clamping
might might be broken and there so this
all of this graphite with these uranium
rods running through the assembly much
uranium I don't have the figure for the
mass of the uranium or the graphite
involved but you see the scale of it now
all of that assembly had to be
surrounded by a shield to prevent
radiation from escaping out to where
people might be look operating the
assembly or doing something outside so
it had to be encased in a concrete
essentially a concrete house the whole
way around the concrete being about five
feet in thickness five feet in thickness
so we see al sections of that around
here
we're looking at what's called what's
called a loading face of this assembly
you can perhaps see vestiges of the
channels that are traveling back away
from us in the photo those that would
represent positions where the uranium
rods were placed and the this loading
face is where those channels those
uranium rods would have been originally
pushed back into the graphite assembly
so there's a loading platform here
that's on a hydraulic crane assembly can
go up and down here a couple fellas
doing something at the front face
they're perhaps pushing some uranium on
back through the assembly and the
control room is over in here and for no
particular reason they
look at the front face here but there
had to be shielding on this front face
as well once you had completed an
operation in there you had shield that
off but the main shielding was all
around here it's the back side of the
reactor the back side one could push
these rods the uranium rod through and
they would fall down into a plenum
chamber and could be collected together
and transported by with remote control
facilities over to a chemical processing
plant which is next door the purpose of
this reactor was to produce the first
viable quantities of plutonium one of
the isotopes of uranium when it's
subjected to this Neutron irradiation
transforms itself into a plutonium the
next element up in the periodic table
from uranium into a plutonium isotope
and from previous measurements and
studies of this that isotope that was
potentially a very good atomic weapon
component recall were in the middle of
in the start of a starting period of the
war and everybody was desperate for new
developments here so the purpose of this
react primary purpose of the reactor was
to produce sizable quantities that the
chemists could get at and purify and
study processes and the physicists
couldn't get at and study processes
would be plutonium for weapons potential
use so though there was no
experimentation as such with all this
neutron radiation which was bouncing
around inside this facility there was
one experiment that I know of that was
performed and that the adult would again
producing information of for further
uses on the project what was called a
pile oscillator a pile oscillator
something moves back and forth the idea
is to have a detector back inside a
section of this configuration a neutron
detector and you move a sample that you
want to study back and forth in its
vicinity you can determine in this but
with this device the capture or
absorption cross section of this medium
for neutron radiation and that's a in
was of great interest in in the
technology at that time again for the
practical use of the project uses to
which the project was devoted so there
was that one for experimental facility
and that's the only use of the neutrons
that I know of other than to continue
the efficiently process in the uranium
inside the assembly well this was used
used throughout the war for producing
more years until the war ended in summer
of 1945 for producing quantities of
plutonium as soon as as this this
reactor was operating new reactors were
under consideration out for construction
out in the state of Washington at
Hanford much larger reaction the much
larger reactors piled much larger piles
I should say which were to produce more
abundant more copious quantities of
plutonium so those were under
construction out there when when this
was operating for the for the in the
first year but this continued this
reactor continued
to operate in that way the total power
production in this reactor was about
thirty-five hundred watts thirty
thirty-five hundred kilowatts excuse me
thirty-five hundred kilowatts three of
three or four megawatts of power
production present-day power reactors
operate roughly at a at a hundred
megawatts 25 or 30 times the operating
power level of this assembly I didn't
mention how do you get that this power
out of here well the power release was
to be obtained by having air stream
along these channels that surround the
uranium plugs that were permeating the
whole assembly having air stream along
there so you needed a big fans and the
exit side to draw air in so all through
this building there was a sucking sound
of air being pulled in here and cooling
reactor taking these this three
megawatts of power thermal power out and
warming up the air and then the air was
to filter it and sent up stacks well at
the end of the war years at the end of
the war in this in the summer of 1945
one of the one of the research
scientists that at this at the
laboratory here
Ernest Wallen who had come down with the
original group from Chicago
Ernest Wallen got to thinking seriously
as other people did how can you use
these facilities for for it
as research tools and he earnestly
Walland decided to see if he couldn't
make use of some of these copious B and
neutrons that were rattling around it
here trying to bring more than some out
to a collimated to and trying to exploit
this diffractive property property of
the of the neutron radiation so he
decided he wanted to try to set up a
diffraction spectrometer in the way that
x-ray people had been doing for for 15
or 20 years earlier bringing a beam out
and diffracting it from samples seeing
if what what novel things might be
available from such studies so Ernie
arranged to have sent down from the
University of Chicago an old x-ray
spectrometer unit that he had used back
up there he did his thesis work in an
earlier time with Compton studying x-ray
scattering by gas samples so in that he
had built an x-ray spectrometer and he
knew that was still up there and he
arranged to have that sent down to Oak
Ridge in the fall of 1945 so he and a
colleague of his Robert Sawyer who was
there during part of the war years from
a university Lehigh rain of configured
this spectrometer so that they could try
to bring him to bring a neutron beam out
from the reactor now off to the side and
have it fall upon this spectrometer
which a spectrometer in general is
something that you can control angular
positions whether do you have a detector
on it and you can move
the detector around and determine a
pattern of scattering or a pattern of
diffraction so that was the idea in in
this in this first effort and his
spectrometer I showed in my next
projection here this was the original
spectrometer the reactor is behind here
off to the backside and there has not
been a channel an open channel through
this graphite assembly that lets
neutrons stream out those that happen to
be coming in the right direction and
stream out from through of the face
through the shield and the face of the
reactor well that had they have to be
contained so there's a another outside
shield pulled up around here so the idea
was to place a monarch remaining crystal
in that beam neutrons were coming out
and falling on a large single crystal of
some sort and being diffracted from that
single crystal one who even if these
were different energy neutrons as they
are thermal neutrons with a thermal
spectrum one wants to select out a monic
remote mount a chromatic section of the
that spectrum a mana energetic section
and that can be done by diffraction from
a crystal one wavelength one energy so
back inside this secondary shield was
this monochrome ating crystal now about
the only crystal large sizable crystal
that was available to Ernie and then
Sawyer at the time with sodium chloride
sodium chloride seems everywhere
and people had learned the technique of
preparing large crystals of sodium
chloride the infrared people were hot on
alkali crystals and they didn't they
were very fine
infrared window material and so the
development people had developed the
technique for the preparing large
crystals of alkali halides most notably
sodium chloride so Ernie obtained this
single crystal a sizable single crystal
of sodium chloride roughly an inch and a
half high and two inches long and a half
inch thick which is an ungodly size for
a single crystals substance back in
those days and used that that as a
monochromatic crystal in here from that
monarch remaining crystal one would have
been a pure diffracted beam from it
coming out and that came out to this
secondary shield onto the and crossed
over the axis of this spectrometer about
which I've spoken there is this old
original University of Chicago x-ray
spectrometer bolted down to a platform
on the floor here and so what the and
this Neutron beam purified Neutron beam
now coming out to and crossing the axis
of this spectrometer one would place
then a further scattering sample or
diffracting sample on this axis so that
the beam would come in and strike the
sample and now be diffracted around from
that sample so here is a detector this
is the most massive thing in the
assembly the detector is itself is not
that bit large
it's about it was about 2 inches in die
and about 15 inches long and it's a
sealed chamber sealed with a an
insulated wire along the center and the
two electrodes the wire and the case and
filled with a special gas boron
trifluoride boron is the important thing
neutrons are absorbing copiously in
boron and so the idea was that a neutron
coming in along the axis of this chamber
would this would be at least partially
absorbed by boron nuclei in this gas and
that would trigger an electrical
response between the wire and the case
which were charged to a high potential
difference between the two so the
chamber is inside here and the
surrounding here is secondary shielding
the shielding is the massive part of the
assembly here all of us shielding to
keep stray radiation away from that
detector but this whole assembly could
can be moved around the axis of the
spectrometer now this weighs this that
has a mass much larger than this
spectrometer shafting can support so
does take off this some of this loading
there were cables running up to a gimble
joined up on the ceiling here so that
the loading of this office access
loading mass loading was supported from
this Universal gimbal joint up on top
here well he's had this had to be
aligned pretty well and I remember after
I came into the picture that all the
troubles that we had in keeping the
blind making sure that this operation of
what angular positioning was a smooth
operation but here is shown on here now
a typical sample a sample in this
footage
a circular sample and this is a powder
sample random crystal light Direction
within the power sealed up between
aluminum windows in a in a plate the
sample thickness you don't get the
oppression here is perhaps a half inch
thick the neutrons had to go through
perhaps a half inch thickness of the
powder sample and in the diffracting
process and the ceiling is just to keep
the powder in there aluminum windows
there aluminum is very transparent to
neutron radiation in operation here one
had to turn handles there's some handles
here turning the detector around also
separately to turning the and
controlling the angular position of the
sample it was all completely hand
operated if he wanted to study the
scattering around here you positioned
this to some point and counted neutrons
that were that were being detected in
this detector over some period that
period might be as short as a minute it
might be as long as 10 minutes or 15
minutes and then after a conclusion of
that and from obtaining that information
bill and turned to a new position and
continue the process powder diffracting
patterns were very time-consuming in in
their in their obtain tainment well with
this sort of assembly our Ernie and
Sawyer indeed found that they could take
powder diffracted diffractions as from
specimens and I show here a powder
pattern obtained you know with a sample
of so again sodium chloride now sodium
chloride power
there's a sodium chloride Monica made
our way up in there that's a single
crystal this is now the powder sample
this is intensity versus scattering
angle position this is what was
presented in a monthly project report at
the Clinton laboratory in April 1946 the
assembly was collected together in late
1945 and early 1946 by Wallen and Sawyer
and here in a couple of diffraction
piece so these are nice well-behaved
looking peak peaks with measurable
intensity would take time you know and
it was a chore to obtain such things but
it was available notice the background
intensity the baseline intensity that
it's underneath all this structure
there's more of it out here but patience
ran out at this time and but notice the
level of background versus signal
intensity here the background is as much
is as much or larger than the signal and
that's a troublesome troublesome feature
you'd and you'd like to do something
about here's another of the very
earliest patterns Ernie
decided to look at at water h2o and not
only water but heavy water d2o and here
are patterns in the obtained in Sawyer
had obtained a thing that was at very
early days of the distinction between
doTERRA have a water and like normal
water the interest here was to see if
the if one could possibly determine as
steady hydrogenous materials hydrogen
containing materials because and this is
very important such information datura
staff
the location of hydrogen atoms in
materials in material structures was
completely not available with
x-radiation nobody had determined what
what the real structure of normal water
was or or frozen water or any other
hydrogenous material because x-rays were
insensitive to hydrogen in in hydrogen
scattering that wasn't expected or not
expected but it was hoped that maybe
with neutron radiation there would be a
difference enough between deuterium and
hydrogen to show them a distinction well
these first patterns which were not that
there was no attempt at analyzing these
but they did show differences here of
this type that you see the this peak
peaking and this these are liquid
patterns so you don't expect sharp
diffraction lines but this peak is
considerably more prominent than for
deuterium do do graded the heavy water
and for the normal light water so this
suggests that again that indeed hydrogen
and deuterium are scattering differently
and that one is sensing that in these
diffraction patterns well there was no
analysis of this at the time that but it
was that was the purpose of the of the
experiments the again this was reported
in this same project we progress report
that I had shown earlier in April 1946 I
came to the laboratory in June of
nineteen forty six a month or two after
this period joined the joined the group
and Wallace and Sawyer decided he was
going to return in the university so he
came with him went back to Lehi and from
then on I worked very closely with
the Ernie Wallen in in in all of the
developments
well this with knowing that you could
take successfully successfully take
powder and diffraction patterns then we
decide decided to look at many materials
trying to get make some sense out of
what was controlling these intensities
what what were the scattering properties
of the different atoms for this neutron
radiation there was something known
about that there had been a compilation
of what was what is called total
scattering cross-sections for a holes
first series of different species atomic
nuclear species but that's not the whole
story that's not the whole thing that's
going to determine these powder peak
intensities it was recognized that there
are different isotopes enmity for
anymore any element for an element
different isotopes might very well
display different scattering properties
and so one had one in in the eventually
one would have to unravel all of that
another thing many nuclei have nuclear
spin and nuclear spin if you have a
nuclear spin then you have two nuclear
spin state scattering amplitudes one
where the neutrons come in this way and
one where the neutrons come in this way
to that nuclear spin so what that
implied and in in in a in a general
sample one would have these nuclei rated
in random of course was not know nothing
to say oh it should be up this
should be up or down whatever under
those conditions what that implied and
the theory had predicted this from the
very earliest that there's that this
code was what we now call the coherent
scattering cross-section should indeed
or may indeed differ from the total
scattering cross-section we had
information on total scattering but
nothing at all on coherent scattering
and the coherent scattering arised
arises because of and this difference
camp comes in because of this spin say
faith possibly the possible difference
in these two spin state scattering cross
sections or scattering amplitudes so in
the long run all of that had to be
unraveled and nothing was known about
this distinction between what you were
going to see in a diffraction pattern
and what would be predicted from these
total scattering cross-sections you had
to look specifically at this quantity
called the coherent scattering
cross-section and that might be anything
from a very low value up to the total
scattering cross-section so that was the
purpose of looking at many of these
early samples to see if we could unravel
and understand these intensities and how
they were affected by cross sections and
what indeed what the basic cross
sections were well this was all very
Torsen with this hand operation and we
were all very anxious to make you try to
improve things so that we didn't have to
sit there through the night and collect
data by hand and write things down and
that we were very fortunate
in the in 1947 when a couple chaps came
down to Oak Ridge as part of what was
called the Oak Ridge training school
after the war the administration
management decided to set up a training
school where they would encourage people
to come in there from universities or
industrial laboratories and learn become
familiar with all the techniques the new
techniques which had been developed
during the war years and which were very
secret so these people were to come in
and and talk with people work in the
laboratories in some case many cases but
mostly to attend lectures that were to
be given by experts who were brought in
for that purpose
so this Oakridge training school which
had perhaps 150 students it sometimes
these these were and were senior people
from from university or from industrial
laboratories that were sent to Oak Ridge
for this purpose and the name Frederick
sites may be familiar when use sites was
who was a very respected solid-state
physicist was brought there as director
of this Oak Ridge Training School well
two of the students that came in one
from the RCA laboratories in New Jersey
and the other from Goodrich rubber
company over an accurate George Martin
from RCA and Bill Davidson from Goodrich
were two of the students and they were
became interested in these neutrons
diffraction patterns and particular
Morton was a very skilled
instrumentation man he had worked with
the
with names workin who was a primary
primary investor developer of electron
microscopes in former years and our RCA
was in the business of selling electron
microscopes the first first of its type
so Martin was but a very skilled
experimentalist is environment
instrument instrumentation man and he
took on the task between the two of them
they took on the task of automatic izing
the this low operating spectrum and they
made many improvements we made many
improvements there this first year in
1947 this is the same spectrometer and
now about a year later than in the
earlier photo here's the basic
spectrometer nothing changed there but
now here's a nice automatic control
operating automatic operating system
here it drives a worm gear with a clock
motor and some cam wheels with some
micro switches so that on demand this
would now change its angular position
and at the same time there was a cadmium
shutter assembly that would go a flock
could flop in or out of the beam that
was falling on the sample and the
electronic system was improved over here
on the control cabinet and now you and
the detector there was just general
improvement and improvement things done
to all of the components now we had a
tray recorder to print out data we
didn't have to be there to see meters
print out data recorder this was a
traffic what was called a traffic
counter you perhaps seen these gimmicks
along the highway where they have a tube
running across and gives a signal and
this thing prints a new number over here
beside the road that was the only type
of recorder that was available digital
recorder that we could find at the time
all the electronic system electronics in
the system amplifiers high voltage power
supplies those were all all had to be
made homemade there was no commercial
instrumentation of that type available
in this period so there were
improvements in these amplifiers vacuum
tubes had gotten better this was long
before the date of day of solid-state
electronics tubes had become better and
less noisy and and that but still here's
a preamplifier and you'll notice it's
sitting up here on top of a pattern
blanket because it's microphonic this
preamplifiers microphonic you have to
separate it from you don't want to bump
it or else you'll get it false false
signal through your circuit well with
the with these sort of improvements this
changed things in a very great very
great fashion one can now put a sample
on here and get things ready and go off
and do something else and come back the
next morning or something and some later
time and look at the data or change
something and do things automatically
analysts spend your time analyzing
things rather than then collecting
things so this was I can't underestimate
the importance of these instrumentation
features that came in at that time and
they were due to our having these two
gentlemen as part of the training school
students as part of the training school
there that
affected them well with this then you
could think of taking patterns regularly
and many more over a given time span we
were interested in the always interested
in these cross sections or amplitudes
cross sections or amplitudes describing
and defining just what different nuclear
species what the real scattering
properties were because that that's data
that hath Navin R that's data that has
to be obtained from a from empirically
and it can't be predicted from theory or
at least theory was far behind the state
stage at the stage where it could
predict how these things should go so we
were very interested in in studying as
many samples and looking for consistency
from one one material to another the
sodium scatter the same way in sodium
chloride as in sodium hydroxide it was
that wasn't a really established thing
so we set out to study these
consistencies looking at chlorine and
different species and to our dismay
there was much that was discrepant and
this gave us a great deal of worry
we were trying at that time to look at
the total diffraction pattern and you
still do that you you look at the total
that the diffuse scattering as well as
the coherent scattering which is showing
up here there should be some if you
combine these two two things together to
represent kind of the total scattering
information that you're getting there
should be
instances we weren't finding that and to
just to illustrate that let me show this
here are some observations made on three
different forms of pure graphic pure
carbon diamond which is pure carbon
graphite pure carbon charcoal pure
carbon
now what dude first think today is that
if I put a diamond sample on here a
graphite in the charcoal I ought to get
the same total scattering if I look at
everything that I can see in the
scattering from this in the scattering
pattern turns out that that isn't the
case it seemed not the case to us we
were not when we added everything up in
the whole pattern including a diffuse
scattering and the coherent scattering
in the peaks there was not consistency
from one to another and that and we
looked at other things as well as this
series and we were having extreme
trouble in making making out obtaining
what we consider to be consistent
information from sample to sample I
remember a conversation that we had with
Eugene Wigner at the time vikner was the
research director at the laboratory and
Ernie Wallen and I Benazir telling him
this our tale of woe hear about these
inconsistencies that we're obtaining
from sample to sample and we were very
puzzled about this and could the could
the great man
think of it there's some help relief for
us for us well he surprised me very much
by saying no he did he he thought that
maybe this was the way way it really is
that maybe maybe there maybe were
there's some other process here going on
that we just don't understand and he
gave us great encouragement to keep on
going and he wasn't taking taken aback
by the fact that that we were getting
these seemingly inconsistent -
observation keep on going back to the
laboratory well it wasn't too long after
that that actually we found the solution
and the solution turned out to be this
and we were both embarrassed by it by
knowing it multiple scattering in
samples multiple scattering in samples
both Ernie and I have had previous x-ray
pattern experience where you scatter
x-rays from samples obtained these
patterns and we never encountered a
problem of this sucker but here things
are very different the neutron
penetration to samples is so much larger
than x-ray penetration through samples
there because the cross-sections are
different that you have you know you
have in the Neutron case we were using
samples which are orders of magnitude
thicker larger samples than in the x-ray
case and now you're susceptible to this
problem of multiple scattering in the
sample block a neutron comes down to
this glob at one position gets scattered
up to
partly and gets scattered again and the
result is that you don't have
consistency in the total scattering in
your pattern so once we would recognize
that that feature in that fact and we
were kicking ourselves that it took us
so long to to recognize it then it all
became clear to us we had to place
controls on our sample physical
geometrical conditions and which we of
course did and then things got clarified
now we were able to get to get
satisfactory consistency from one sample
to another sample with a recognition of
this troublesome multiple scattering
problem well we had this great interest
in in knowing whether you could
determine hydrogen atoms in crystals
there was this earlier observation that
I showed on ion water but that was too
complicated to interpret so we searched
for crystals that contained hydrogen and
which which might very might have a nice
ordered crystal structure but it wasn't
known whether the hydrogen's were indeed
ordered in these materials well one of
the simplest of the hydrogen hydrogen
containing crystals is this sodium
hydride sodium hydride one to one and if
you take an x-ray pattern of this you
see only the sodium when you know
nothing about what the position or what
the hydrogen atoms are doing but if the
x-ray pattern shows a well-developed
pattern characteristic of the sodium
lattice that's known very nicely from
the x-ray pattern but the question is
what what are the hydrogen's
was doing and that's what the neutrons
can hope to show so here are two
patterns of the same position in the
diffraction pattern from two
isotopically different samples sodium
deuteride
and sodium hydride and you see the
patterns are completely different
so this says immediately that you're
seeing the deuterium or the hydrogen in
these patterns if these were just
looking at sodium atoms they ought to be
the same why the difference well the
difference
turning it turns out to be that the
algebraic sign of the deuterium
scattering is opposite the out from the
algebraic sign of the hydrogen
scattering and that's why the two
patterns are seemingly reversed here big
peak here little peak little peak big
peak and that persists to moral the
diffraction pattern so here sure enough
here
what we're seeing is the real
determination of the hydrogen atom
positions in this in these two crystals
this was the first end real indication
of the d1 could and this is a very
important feature nowadays there's a lot
of biological structure work that goes
on with Neutron diffraction in Neutron
diffraction studies looking at
determining where hydrogen atom
positions are in organic polymeric
biological materials that's a important
field of application there are other
applications that I can go on here but
I'm afraid I've gone too long here but
let me close by showing one other
pattern here
this is a different type of neutron
pattern this is what's called a law a
pattern in this lao a pattern one uses a
direct beam of radiation from the
reactor not being crystal monochrome
ated so that you have all Neutron
energies all neutron wavelengths falling
on a crystal a single crystal under such
conditions the different wavelengths and
the different atomic planes in the
crystal diffract the radiation to
specific directions and one obtains this
spot pattern rather than a a peak
pattern as in the powder peak assembly
so we have this lao e these lousy spots
here well this was not the first picture
that was obtained there were quite a few
attempts before getting one that looked
even as good as this and this has
several interesting features about one
is that there's a first of all it's a
photograph there's photographic film and
our photographic film is insensitive to
neutron radiation
so you knew you'd do it use a trick here
you put a piece of scintillating
material next to the film neutrons come
in and are absorbed in the scintillator
in this case it was a sheet of indium
metal or the indium then releases after
and capturing neutrons releases a
charged particle and that charged
particle reacts nicely with the
photographic emulsion so the sensitivity
comes from this combination of
scintillator
and photographic film so in the there
was an indium sheet here covering the
film and there was section of that
cutout in the circuit hole
circular region to let the focus of the
direct beam away so it wouldn't sin late
and over cloud the whole the whole film
and we wobbly obviously gotten in
off-center the whole assembly is
off-center and me exposure but there are
two other features in here one if you
look closely at these spots you see
notice that they all have a double
structure it's particularly pronounced
here yeah there's a double and that
puzzled us very much why why should it
be this doubling neutron spots is that
perhaps connected with the fact that
there are two spin States in the nuclear
scattering from this crystal well we
were never anxious to explore that and
see if we could explain the origin of
this doubling and as it turned out after
this exposure was made and this exposure
took twenty twenty hours a long time
exposure twenty hour exposure just after
this exposure was completed the reactor
had to shut down for a breakage of one
of these fuel element cans did one of
the cans containing the uranium had had
developed a pin hole and the uranium
inside it oxidized and it had exploded
sensually exploded inside the reactor so
there was no way of operating the
reactor under those conditions they had
to get it out of there and that took
some three weeks for them to cleanse
that get back to operation so it took us
a long time to ponder over this before
we could hope to
to try to do something else to try to
explain these this doubling of these
lousy spots well it turned out that
after we got back in business that the
spot structure was something associated
with a particular crystal we used the
crystal had a mosaic layer on its two
phases entrance and exit and a mosaic
layer means that the crystal scatters
more strongly so what these spots
represent are effectively scattering
from the front side of the crystal and
the back side of the crystal and that's
somehow or other showing up all around
here so that was a trivial explanation a
good crystal with without this mosaic
layer layer on the surface doesn't show
this but another interesting feature you
notice that there's kind of a band
structure here well that and you know
there's nothing oh no way you would
expect that that turns out to be the
world's first neutron radio graph
feature the the band structure
represents the collection between cheap
pieces of India we didn't have enough
indium or in to cover this thing so we
had strips that we kept together by
strips of scotch tape scotch tape line
scotch tape line another one here so
this is showing the radio graphing of
the scotch tape that was used to hold
these indium strips to her
well that is that set us off the
thinking you know what could what else
could we do if a piece of scotch tape
shows up here like this there must be
better uses that one can
exploit in in this indeed that's the
case
people now radiograph large assemblies
metal castings or other things with
neutrons in in the way that normal
rating graphing has done and exploring
exploiting and the particular prop
penetration properties of the neutron
radiation well these were very exciting
times back then and I often think how
really how exciting it was almost any
corner you turned there'd be new vistas
showing up and we tried to we explored
many many corners at the time then our
own reflectional I'm sure that there is
no difference today than back then
almost anything that one can look at
there is new information and new things
to uncover so I think the challenges
into in present day physics present day
science are loom just as important as
prominently as they did back at this
time so I say that to our younger
friends who were with us fear thank you
very much scattering cliff story is so
rich he actually only began to scratch
the surface of all his many
contributions magnetism Paul right to
try technology basically twenty
properties I guess remaining for
for the next next installment of the how
did you first get the idea that came a
year or two after these things that I've
chatted about and we were set off on
this route by our desire to look for
what was called paramagnetic scattering
paramagnetic scattering it was something
that theorists had predicted would occur
from a material of a paramagnetic
material and at that time a paramagnetic
material as it is today represents a
collection of magnetic centers where
there was randomness in the in the
direction or the orientation of these
magnetic centers paramagnetic material
in contrast to a ferromagnetic material
where they were considered to be all
lined up now in paramagnetic with a
paramagnetic sample if one scatters
neutrons from it there you expect to
find a diffuse scattering in the pattern
associated with this random collection
of magnetic centers this was shown in a
very powerful theoretical paper by
Halpern and Johnson back in years
earlier than this period I was talking
about so that it
this and so that this was a prediction
and one that was capable of observation
with the technology that was available
here so we were interested in looking
for this paramagnetic scattering in
paramagnetic media and the first thing
that we looked at was in a material a
typical paramagnetic substance hematite
hematite fe2o3 hematite there are strong
magnetic ions are anions in this in this
substance and it was known that you
could you could make or you could
measure a paramagnetic susceptibility
and and obtained certain values of the
susceptibility and could interpret that
it's temperature dependence upon the
strength of these magnetic ions which
were at random so we looked at that
first and that that was present we could
see that we also looked at another one
manganese oxide where again you have a
strong strongly magnetic manganese iron
present in the material manganese oxide
mono valent strong magnetic iron and
that was again has a nice paramagnetic
susceptibility and we looked at that in
the what we found there was the there
was indeed this diffuse scattering but
it showed some structure in the diffuse
scattering instead of showing a
uniformly varying magnetic paramagnetic
scattering you could showed some
structure and that suggested I had had
experience with short and long range
order in crystals prior to that time
that suggested that if we were to
coolest medium down the sample down that
this short rain what's called short
range or
might develop into coherent long-range
order and sure enough when we finally
did that experiment by cooling the
magnet manganese oxide down to a low
temperature the long-range order had
developed so that the origin of the
magnetic scattering all came in the
interest of certain in the interest of
searching for the paramagnetic effects
and then the order of magnetic lattice
scattering followed from that but that
came in in nineteen forty eight forty
nine nineteen fifty years after these
experiments that I've just been
described gore the core reactor
difference is the eleven months it took
with the clinton reactor it'll be eleven
years all right let's thank once again
you